اه اه اه
وكلما رأيت الدعائم تمر ، أفكر في المركز
هل سيحدث هذا؟ هؤلاء الناس يواصلون البحث عن أوزان ثقيلة لا يمكن تصورها
لذلك أعتقد أنها القدرة.
اسمي روك ج
أنا فنان للوجبات الخفيفة من ABBA
[موسيقى]
أوو
أوو أوو
[موسيقى]
بدأت عام 2005
في البداية ، دخلت مركز الحجر.
كشر ، جمعت 2
الآن هذه وظيفة
[موسيقى]
في بعض الحالات ، يمكن لأي شخص أن يقوم بها بسهولة ، لكن
الثلاثة الأولى ، الخمسة بالنسبة لي ، تغيرت أيضًا كثيرًا بطرق مختلفة.
بغض النظر عن مدى صعوبة رؤية مثل هذه الشروط المركزية المعقدة مع
كتبت شيئًا يسمى الجاذبية ، وأستخدمه في المركز.
5 نجوم لـ 100 إرسالية إدارية
أفعل ذلك بعدة طرق ، إلخ.
ملف سماعة كرسي الحجر
لقد انتهيت من دراجة نارية البقر الأكثر انسكابًا.
أنا أحقق النتائج لأنني يجب أن أغوص في هذا الأمر.
حركة اليد العضلية التدمير الذاتي
أنا لا أتنفس لشراء العسل في النهاية
سأقدمها لك عندما تضع يدك عليها
آه ، نحن عادة نعيش في عجلة من أمرنا ، ثم نحن
دعونا نعيش بشكل أبطأ قليلا
بعد الاستقالة كمقيم ، يُقال إنه شخص يمكنه تحقيق نتائج لكل شيء.
أعتقد أنه حدث لأن لديّ إيجابية ويقين
[موسيقى]